Welcome back, everyone
It's Charlie.
This will be my new Scarlet Witch video.
Elizabeth Olsen talking about
the return of the character to the MCU.
We all believe that she was still alive.
So explain what's going on.
Is a bunch of Easter eggs here,
and they do have
a bunch of plans for her in future
MCU movies and Disney Plus series.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
is a bunch of really big stuff coming up
in a couple really big wandavision spin
offs of all the Disney Plus shows
so far is the only one that has two
spinoffs already.
You may have seen the clip
of Elizabeth Olsen
talking about coming back
as Scarlet Witch.
This is her at a convention
explaining what's going on,
What we see a storyline for one done.
Do you want.
Well, honestly, if I were to tell you
exactly what I would want,
I think I would
maybe be spoiling something because
just heaven.
Kevin Feige genuinely asks us
what we want to do with the character,
and then he does it.
So I think what
I don't know if I can share,
but I just want to come back.
Oh, the funny thing about that clip is
you try not to give away spoilers
in the way that she says it.
If I were to say anything, they would be.
Spoilers is just the fact
that Kevin Feige listens to the actors
and will do pretty much whatever they want
to do within certain limits.
Elizabeth Olsen In the past has talked
about how she wants redemption
for Scarlet Witch.
That's what she'll be focused on
when she comes back
with a bunch of other stuff happening too
at the same time.
They always had the plan for her
to turn evil
during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness,
but they changed the way that they did
that a couple of different times
in some versions of the movie.
She waited till later in the film
before she was revealed as a villain.
So that felt like something was missing
between Wandavision in Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness that explained
why she'd gone so evil.
That's mostly a result of all the reshoots
during Doctor Strange Multiverse
of Madness, these kind of yada yada yada
over a lot of stuff during that movie.
But at the end of that film
she destroys the Darkhold Temple,
which is meant to be the only one
in the entire multiverse.
Like there were many copies
of the Darkhold that had spread
across the multiverse in different
universes, but only one Darkhold temple.
All the books had been copied
from the writings inside that one temple.
The way they explain it in
the movie is that when she destroyed
the temple, it automatically destroyed
all the other copies of the book.
When she brings down the top of one door
and you see this flash of hex energy
in that set, essentially
what happened during
that is her own powers protected her
the same way that she used her powers
to create the hex in Wandavision without
really understanding how she did it.
Like her grief manifested physically.
And it was so powerful
that the hex is what came out.
So the already established
the idea that her body
can automatically use her powers
without it.
Her brain
really thinking about it actively.
The other funny example here too,
is that if you're big Avatar,
the Last Airbender fan,
if you remember the boy in the Ice Age
got stuck in the ice for over 100 years.
That's
because when he fell into the water,
a hundred plus years ago, his body
automatically went into the Avatar state
and protected him in that bubble
for a hundred plus years,
like he was in the Avatar
state for over 100 years.
So you have to imagine Scarlet Witch stuck
in the Avatar state in this protective
bubble for a couple years
until they bring her back.
She won't be stuck in there
for over 100 years like ING was.
Right now, Marvel
does plan to bring the character back
during Avengers Kang Dynasty,
but also she's supposed to have a cameo
during the Agatha Coven of Chaos series.
I don't know
if that's going to be a flashback, though.
She will be back in present day
like regular Scarlet
Witch Back by Avengers Kang Dynasty.
There's only a couple of years away.
Now there are the other Wandavision
spinoffs.
Like I just mentioned,
Agatha Coven of Chaos.
The Vision Quest TV series
is also meant to be a Wandavision spinoff
with a White Vision character.
She might have some kind of cameo
during that,
but it could also be a flashback
or just a hallucination of someone.
It could just be white vision
Remembering her.
One of the reasons
why she's so important to Agatha
Coven of Chaos, though,
is because her power, her spell literally
trapped Agatha
in the spell inside Westview.
The minute the Scarlet Witch
went unconscious during this moment here,
like she's not absolutely conscious
while this is happening,
that's when her spell in West went down
and Agatha was freed.
A lot of the characters from Wandavision
are coming back
during Agatha Coven of Chaos.
Are introducing a couple more ones too.
But during the series, Scarlet Witch
is a big character
on the tip of everyone's tongues.
Everybody's
talking about what happened to her,
what happened with her during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
They're also supposed to bring back
an adult version, a resurrected
version of her son,
Billy Kaplan, who's played by Joe Long.
Now, that's a bit of a rumor.
It could be another character,
but it does seem like he's
playing the older version of Billy.
During the series, Agatha
is trying to protect him and his power
from this other coven of witches
played by Aubrey Plaza.
Right now, the report is that
she's playing a version of Morgan Lafe,
who's just one of the more evil
magic users inside the MCU,
because we know they're doing
a version of Young Avengers.
They started to tease that
during Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania
with Cassie Lang's character,
and there were some deleted scenes
that I talked about
where they more literally try
to set up Young Avengers.
Of course,
they plan on using adult versions of Billy
and Tommy during that,
like they did during the comics.
But we don't know where adult Tommy
is going to appear during the MCU next.
He might have a cameo during Agatha
Coven of Chaos.
He might cameo during the Vision
Quest series.
They haven't said
absolutely when the young Avengers
team will come together
formally for the first time.
There's still a couple of characters
they haven't introduced yet,
but most of the young Avengers characters
you've seen in Marvel Phase four series,
The Vision Quest series, is supposed to be
tied more directly to young Avengers.
But the really cool thing
a lot of people have been asking about
because one of the big things about
Scarlet Witch is history is her connection
to the mutants in X-Men characters,
the X-Men comics.
Elizabeth Olsen has talked about this.
The Marvel people have talked about this.
They would love long term
to have her crossover
with the new version of the X-Men,
be in those new solo movies
in whatever the Disney Plus series
they have based on X-Men characters.
After Secret Wars.
Right now, it just
seems like Marvel is waiting to release
that X-Men solo movie
until After Secret Wars,
and that'll be the beginning
of a huge X-Men focus saga.
Like we have the multiverse saga
right now.
You're seeing a few X-Men characters,
like Hugh Jackman's
characters coming back in Deadpool three.
We've seen Professor
X cameos with Patrick Stewart.
They'll be some more of that during Secret
wars, maybe even before that.
There's supposed to be a bunch of Fox
Marvel
characters cameo ing in Deadpool three
because they're kind of doing a version
of Deadpool Kills the Marvel Universe.
So is this the opportunity
for a bunch of different cameos
from different, quote unquote, universes?
But that's all meant to set up secret wars
where they have a bunch of legacy
characters come back
and they do some multiverse
Avengers action.
Then I think after they use
that as a big swansong
for a lot of these legacy
X-Men characters,
then they're going to do way more core MCU
rebooted versions of the characters
with new actors,
and that's what we'll start seeing Scarlet
Witch crossover with more X-Men movies.
If you don't remember,
Marvel is actually doing new seasons
of X-Men, the Animated Series, the first
season of that will premiere later
this year.
Of course,
I'll do episode videos for that,
but Scarlet Witch
is actually canon to that series.
She actually showed up during X-Men,
the animated series,
obviously not played by Elizabeth Olsen,
where I would have come before you
if I had known you were alive.
We'll never know, will we?
But still,
it's another good example of Scarlet
Witch is tied to the X-Men stories.
One of the reasons
why they were able to use her
in Avengers Age of Ultron with Quicksilver
is is because little loopholes,
because they both shown up in Avengers
comics and X-Men comics.
So there was like a weird rights issue
where
both Fox and Marvel were able
to use the characters for a little while.
Obviously, that's all moot now.
Marvel got the rights
to all the characters back.
There's reports about there
being some weird contractual issues,
preventing them from recasting
some of the major X-Men characters,
and that's the reason why they're waiting
until after Secret Wars.
So there might be some practical things
behind the scenes going on
with all the new versions of the X-Men.
But either way, long term, we will see
new versions of the characters.
We will see Scarlet Witch crossover
with them, has some cool stories.
What I'm really hoping is that once
we get to Secret Wars and we see like some
real full blown crossover with Fox X-Men
characters and MCU characters,
we see Scarlet Witch
with the different versions of Magneto
like Michael Fassbender, Magneto and also
Ian McKellen, Magneto, where she starts
talking about her parentage.
I'm going to go with Sir Ian McKellen.
And for those of you asking about
Quicksilver coming back in Secret Wars
or a crossover movie like that, Aaron
Taylor-Johnson is now in the Sony
Marvel movies playing a version of Kraven
for Sinister Six spin offs in the future.
He looks super swole right now, so there's
always the chance that he comes back.
But I think that he's mostly focused on
what's going on in the Sony Marvel movies
with all the Spider-Man
spin offs right now,
who would say, okay,
hey, give it another try?
There's just
just a bit too close to the kneecap.
So if we get a version of Quicksilver
coming back,
I think it'll probably be the Evan Peters
version of Quicksilver
and not the Ralph Bohner
version of Quicksilver,
like the actual Fox
Marvel version of Quicksilver.
What will probably happen,
though, is we see more Agatha
Coven of chaos footage
and they start releasing teasers.
For that.
We'll get more Easter eggs
for Scarlet Witch coming back.
There's a lot of other stuff
going on in there.
They're supposedly incorporating more
aspects of actual Mephisto in the MCU.
There have been some Easter eggs
in the past and reportedly Sacha
Baron Cohen is actually playing a version
of the character in a couple different
upcoming Disney Plus series.
But I'm really hoping, you know, long term
she's going to have some crossovers
with Doctor Doom as well, like Doctor
Strange, Dr.
Doom crossovers in Scarlet Witch,
Doctor Doom crossovers, just because
there's so many new magic based characters
coming into the MCU.
And Doctor Doom works well in pretty much
all those different stories.
There are also some really cool Dr.
Doom, Scarlet Witch based comic book
stories, too, but have no fear.
A long time ago,
Kevin Feige said that Scarlet Witch
was just really critical
to the future of the MCU, so
they always had plans for her
to be a big character going forward.
That's one of the reasons why she's joking
about revealing things about the future.
Revealing spoilers.
Oh, if I said anything,
it would be a spoiler
because they're definitely planning on
bringing me back.
Big reminder that The Mandalorian Season
three starts releasing episodes next week.
Of course
I'll do videos for all those episodes.
Everyone click here for that.
Agatha Coven of Chaos.
First Look video for them filming footage.
And here for that opening scene from The
Mandalorian Season three Episode one.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.